Kevin Van Horn hi you're here to show
off rich dumb battle made I am actually
may just this is a game that is on early
access on Steam but by God did it have a
big booth at PAX did it really a lot of
spots to play it at PAX a lot of people
checking it out
and it's a it's a game of people talking
about it so we're gonna hop on in this
for the folks at home who may not be
familiar with Richard embattled mache
could you give us the battle jela Marsh
Lamar likes them battle amage if you
could give us the air the elevator pitch
on this bad boy so first person mage
actually it is first person mage action
by Marvel I don't know look one of the
cool things about it though is that
there's no there's no like mana meter
how do you cast spells without mana yeah
I know right you just kind of do your
thing you you you cast spells off as
long as you can until you die so did I
see a meter in the bottom left corner
man that is your health oh that is your
I guess the interesting thing about
mages in most role-playing games is and
boom that's what happens when you're
dying they have to be sort of nerf to
[ __ ] by virtue of the fact that you're
coupling up with warriors and stuff like
that yeah you don't have armor on yeah I
don't have armor on but else of a sorts
that's again that's like the health
meters down down there at the bottom
okay you don't really have armor but you
do have a shield so I will activate my
knee that's called a ward I don't think
that works you've got pretty well juiced
no don't know where you play as a Maj
not a battle amaz yeah that's true
that's true but you know this this mage
is born for a battle so you've got it's
down at the bottom you see so I've got
cold I can also switch over to two fire
spells when I wanted to then you have
three basic three basic spells at any
given time a projectile want got the
projectile one you've got the area
damage one and you've got your shield
gotcha
but there's another interesting aspect
of this that I'll get to in a minute but
first I want to go ahead and kill stuff
so the game is oh this game looks kind
of squiddy Welch
yeah they get well it uses CryEngine so
it's it's it's a pretty good looking
game maximus H so but you'll notice
but as I go along I I earn like some of
these these glowy bit glowy bits and so
that you said you see that gave me is
destructive mastery so that comes into
the games other really cool part which
is that you can go in and you create
your own spells cool so this is this is
the cool bit so you get all these little
bits you can synthesize these things
together to get some kind of like random
spell bit and then you can go in and and
craft something so to show you how the
crafting works like I there are other
types of spells besides fire and ice
that you earn over time for a game but
for now I'm gonna choose ice I thank you
fire slowly probably I don't think heart
and out of the options so but I'm gonna
I'm gonna choose ice and then I need to
choose let's see what's going on here do
you choose a spot you're really killing
and making this yeah I know I'm really
I'm really good at this bit here so I'll
go ahead and use ice now where there we
go
now let's move to order words so so I
can choose let's say impacted targeting
pattern so this is going to be a just
regular like ice bolt that you throw or
whatever so ice Lance as you see and
then I have to add a buff to it so I can
add a little bit to the destruction I
can add to the mastery stay in this case
I'm going to go ahead and do and add
destruction these are all ones that
you've picked up during the yeah these
are things that I've earned just by
playing and it shows you what you're
gonna get 37 and a half damage mentions
my chance to slow so frozen duration you
get shatter bonus so they're they're
they're really cool things then you
craft it actually it shows you that
you've got it and then I'm gonna go
ahead and equip it this seems to be so I
have every once in a while like a game
comes out on especially nerdy access a
lot recently that is almost seems to
have been like a game a bunch of people
wish existed I mean I seems to be
scratching some itch like maybe dark
messiah of my magic did but without
being sort of hamstrung by all the rest
of the combats off the back game had to
do
with the archery and the swords and
stuff so now you see like my cold bolt
is doing more damage I'm doing 38 damage
yeah they're only does a number well I
was doing 30 before first our dodge when
you first start yeah so the other thing
is that you get this this dodge thing so
I can dodge really any direction I end
up doing a lot of dodging backwards kind
of in this in the serious Sam you know
escape the oncoming animal kind of thing
and as your dodge have fired like area
damage as far as I can tell the dot the
dodge doesn't actually do any damage
just looks Danny where's all that fire
stuff coming could you make a dodge that
does something I don't know it propped
maybe but it doesn't shoot unlikely is
like for the most part right there yeah
like you've dodged back and then it's oh
gosh so that's the area of effect attack
you can do one of my favorite things and
another one of my favorite thing so it
reminds me of the borderlands which is
like some of them have you know damage
over time and you see the little numbers
popping up this game looks really good
for this gorgeous looks you look super
oh I'm it's the orange thing oh thank
you Chris
both in terms of its graphics and I've
read some stuff about this over the past
couple weeks where they are very much
involved in the communities sort of
directing where this game goes or where
they're focusing on this I will say I
think this game is super cool that's one
of the reasons I'm like this open on the
lobby it's just because I think it's
super cool right now I have no freaking
idea why I'm in this place of what these
things are why you have come to the wild
exactly
there there there are some attempts to
tell a story here and there but that's
one of the things that hasn't really
made it into the game but I do know that
the leads are gonna be voiced by Troy
Baker oh wow and Jennifer Hale no
kidding sweet oh they do have some good
talent lined up along with nolan north
like two of the most prominent video
game voice actors
and just got word as well when a
developer's four little battle may just
also in the chat oh good good good
everyone so if you have any questions by
all means ask that individual in there
if you have any questions for Kevin
please feel free to to send to us
especially if you're not in twitch chat
and somebody 11:02 one on gamespot is
asking is there any sort of story to
this game you've touched on that is
there even in terms of like the world
that when you first load into the game
is it very linear is it well you don't
really it's it's fairly linear when you
first go in and speaking of storytelling
now there's some story happening but I
like I said the I don't really know a
whole lot of what's going on there's not
a whole lot of exposition you meet this
character and and she and these these
folks are sort of helping you out but
there's no there's no voiceover it's
just sort of indicated on what's
happening on the screen and it's in
media res like I said there's no intro
so I don't know yet but you do come to
some cool parts where you where you
activate what looked to be memories like
you see ghosts in act what looks to be a
you know an event that has happened in
the past how long until you think
someone mods this so that the every time
you use a spell they shout out Harry
Potter spell words it can't happen soon
enough as far as I'm concerned the
problem is that it's really only the
same it's you know they're it's not a
lot of variety of spells in terms of
like yeah you're not going to be its
expel a Armus expelliarmus be smelly on
battle spells so yeah like I said I
think this game is really super cool is
that blue thing the wizard equivalent of
an exploding red barrel actually no this
would replenish my shield if I needed
any but luckily I don't have any you're
all [ __ ] I'm all shielded up because
after after my first embarrassing Jack
this environment is really it's really
gorgeous as I think is pretty absolutely
yeah sometimes I'm gonna go around and
and see what we can do and this is
available as steam early access at the
moment for I believe it's 20 bucks 20
bucks $19.99
and it's it's a healthy amount of
content - it's not just hey look at this
you know it's very pretty it's made with
CryEngine 3 here's a little taste
there's a lot going on here there's a
lot to do I got to the end of all of
this sort of jungle stuff here and I was
surprised that there was like I was a
Sauron I next comes the ice level so
here's an example of the storytelling
okay sadly like I said the you sort of
see these ghosts and unfortunately his
Cape has lots of problem oops I love
that but early access yeah early access
oh yeah I have a question Kevin probing
early access reviews here for a couple
months now yeah you know because these
are games that people can pay money for
invest a substantial amount of time for
you know there's a sort of a spectrum
along which the early access moniker
covers some of these games are worthy of
a review of an analysis for our audience
is is lich in battle mage are we working
on a review i am hoping to do yeah i'm
hoping to do an early access review
myself of this game okay cool just
because i played enough of it but i feel
like we should be talking about it
unfortunately since i'm in the middle of
playing Elder Scrolls online and hasn't
has it hasn't gotten a chance to take
first primary and there's there's death
for usually when you start dying a bit
that's your clue to start going in and
making some more spells oh okay yeah so
Sid burn 19 mr. cards are on the chat
house is there cooldown to be spells
there's no management
no there is no I mean it's it's
basically as soon as it's as soon as
it's off you're off to the races as soon
as it's complete you can fire it up
again yeah yeah there's there's no oh
the animation time is really the
cooldowns right you know so and that's
one of the things I love about it you
know you don't have to worry about this
stuff it's like you really do feel like
an awesome battle mage like just
flinging fire everywhere is there any
like super big spells you can cast over
like much wider area or is it I
scale-wise is it very much well once you
start building them up you do well you
this is pretty much what I what I had so
far but once you start really building
these things up some of them are really
interesting especially when they slow
slow things down or they can freeze the
moment you know momentarily and things
like that so and there there's some big
bosses unfortunately I'm not gonna be at
the point where I where I'll be showing
a boss but there are some there are some
bosses and the one that ends this
particular chapter is pretty not not
hard I would say but he demands a lot of
patience from you how far away are we
from that a ways that you're not gonna
see really yeah you just keep murdering
fools all three four and I tend bad
about forgetting that I have the shield
because I get so involved in the in
Windows two L's are using dodges yeah I
really get to get involved and using
dodge a lot of the time especially
because when you do that it's it's got a
little bit of that bullet time effects
to it yeah it looks cool like boom you
got motion blur in bullet time all in
one you guys all of the all of the
gaming tricks at one time is there a
benefit to having your enemies swing and
be open like that before you cast or is
it well some of them have not as far as
I can tell but some of them do have
their own shields like like my shield
here they have their own and they can
you know you have to whittle that down
before you can start doing damage to
them but you can visually see their
their shields sort of beginning to get
fainter and he'll start to flicker once
you kill this guy could do me a favor
you just stand in the sunlight and look
oh yeah I'm just a video porno
nice look at I cry yeah I mean look at
those things that you may not even
notice as you're playing hey Oh somebody
something attacking me Oh
jerk I was looking at the Hawaiian shark
demons opening our little burst how far
away do you think bound ages from a
court of unquote full of fight the world
of early access games well I don't think
we know quite yet but I do know that
there's a big patch coming coming we
made oh really is it oh no no it is it
is later this week yeah I'm so sorry and
I know that they're gonna be adding some
stuff with the storytelling cool I know
that they're gonna be doing doing some
other things adding different spell
types so I'm excited to see where this
game goes because the one thing that's
really missing for me is context yeah
and as soon as we get that in there I
think this could potentially be a hit
because frankly it just feels really
good to be in a really pretty place
throwing magic everywhere you know this
is this is what games are all about for
me it doesn't want to be a powerful
bottle amaz not LaMarche
bad amaz light stone battle homage
available currently
listen bout me on Steam early access for
$19.99 kind of an hour thank you very
much for coming out oh my pleasure
yeah this Shambhala mage I recommend the
game go go play